[Music]
hello there
reject nation on Greg Alba if you don't
know salamander Sallie Lamonica of the
Sally of the fishes you got to go check
out her YouTube channel as soon as you
can hey guys we're gonna watch this
video from screen read an awesome movie
channel 22 deleted Pokemon scenes that
never made it to America
cartoons anyone oh yeah bloody hey guys
listen before we do this I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's followed us
over at our patreon page over there who
we do weekly Q&A zazz well as TV show
reaction stream belongs for many shows
that includes my hero academia attack on
Titan Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
one punch man supernatural Gotham Cobra
Kai season two and the haunting a hill
house and several those shows have
reaction highlights included those are
attack on Titan my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood supernatural
so go check us out over there today and
then later on check out her channel men
first 1997 well things in North America
might think they know everything about
their favorite animated franchise they
might be surprised to learn there are
actually a ton of deleted scenes that
never made it from overseas and
grillings anime has we mission about
things like showing a little extra skin
in the same way that American TV shows
often have to be chaste sensors which
often results in the show is having to
be altered from their original versions
before making it to the u.s. interest
the Pokemon episode of beauty in the
beach is one episode and in particular
that had to be seriously edited before
it was given the OK to air mostly
because of a scene where once the gang
makes it to the port of this the beach
and are enjoying some fun of the Sun we
see Team Rocket's chains like we've
never seen him before
he crossed dresses in the APIs
Oh female friends about the two round
balloons and this is the reason American
stands for a sex change these things
were taught and the beauty and the
beauty was eventually released has a
lost episode where the end of a pattern
here man you'll soon understand what we
mean another scene that was deemed too
scandalous for American eyes was from an
episode titled got miltank that aired in
the States in 2002 okay so we see
cyndaquil and Meowth wind up lost in the
desert badly heard and separated from
the rest of the group in order to
survive they're taken to a mill tank who
was able to heal them that they drink
it's feeling milk drink ability only in
the original Japanese version the to
drink from it like a baby calf night
which proved just a little too raunchy
for American sensibilities oh my so keen
to have an Arab American TV in the
episode D kangaskhan kid misty ash and
Brock meet a young boy who was raised by
Kangaskhan all of the jungle book only
instead of some fun songs about the bare
necessities and all that this episode
took a bit of a creepy turn and the
scene that was deleted the young boy
asks Misty if he can
well drink from her me you get the
picture
the camera zooms in on her chest as she
smacks the boy out of the way oh my god
my childhood games were all bound to be
a little more spicy than was appreciated
in more ways than one
take pokemon gold and silver for
instance game the beauty trainer was
depicted in a blue and white outfit that
included a pair of shorts for the
American release the makers of the game
actually had to add a few inches on to
the length taking them from mid thigh to
Neela joy the shorts were deemed too
scandalous that might seem like a lot of
work for a tiny detail and are pretty
gun-happy these days usually they come
with at least a pg-13 rating well the
creators of Pokemon felt that it wasn't
such a big deal to feature an episode
packed full of guns most of the time
being pointed at kids so you know what
happened
was banned entirely because there was
just so much gun brandishing that they
couldn't edit it out with any episode
left to spare
particularly a moment in which the game
wardens of the Safari Sun points a gun
squarely between Ash's eyes point-blank
range only never fired it we can see how
this might have set off a couple of
alarm bells not in this day and age
directly pointed at your preteen
protagonist maybe isn't the best
influence sometimes these edits become a
little bit silly take for example a
scene that was changed in the episode no
way out
during the episode we see males and Team
Rocket struggling to survive inside a
freezing igloo while James Ponder's what
the crew were going to do to survive
health takes out a couple of matches and
lights one to keep warm and the American
version is matchless changed to a
birthday candle shoulders amusing
matches all those extra diligent about
making sure the images of the cards were
family-friendly the original humanist
and were definitely not like in the case
of the grammar card in the Japanese
version he is seen peeking out from
under a manhole coos put the eyes one of
the most horrifying Wars of all time
right such a crazy idea is it you think
so but in the case of Pokemon that was
apparently not so obvious in the episode
All Things Bright and Beautiful there is
a seam that features mouth James and
Jesse talking to a big group of Team
Rocket grunts all in their standard
uniform then in one very startling
moment everyone does the exact same oh
my god and they didn't mr. in World War
two was obviously God for American
audiences and we have no questions not
Germany
when dealing with the children's Marcin
was alcohol well it's always hard to
tell what an animated character is
eating or drinking they took no chances
with the possibility that they might be
making drinking looked glamorous or
appealing to the younger set Oasis
critical situation Bach Cohen versus
Jeff tile they made a very subtle switch
Giovanni the leader of Team Rocket is
seen sipping on wine out of a standard
long-stemmed wine glass for broadcast in
the States the stem was removed to make
it more ambiguous it's not understand
why the episode the power of terror was
altered for American broadcast after the
events of 9/11 or why the network would
no longer want an episode airing with a
title like that well it did originally
air in the States in 1998 immediately
after the national tragedy the episode
was removed they also pulled the episode
from broadcast entirely after September
11 only choosing to put it back into
rotation over a year later funny enough
the United States is the only place
where the episode has this title it's
otherwise known as capture at the
pokemon tower and if they had stuck with
that it might not have had to be pulled
out of the lineup in the first place
we will not change us title on TV these
days cartoon nudity is still pretty
taboo in America it is a kids show after
all
so in order for the opening song to be
appropriate for Western audiences there
was actually a lyric that had to be
edited out from the original version
well the song remains completely epic
and one of the best anthems ever and
once contains a lyric that might make
some parents squirm it used to go I'll
get you Pokemon even in fire and grass
and forests and ground and clouds that
girl's skirt followed by a little scream
huh not all changes and cuts are made
because they're deemed too offensive or
inappropriate sometimes it's just a
matter of translation between cultures
the episode the ghost of maidens peak is
a perfect example of that in the episode
we see the characters using something
called a food ax in order to protect
themselves from gasoline so food ax is a
Shinto talisman that is common and would
be well known in Japanese culture but
would be difficult to explain to
American children in a short amount of
time so for the West oh who the hell was
changed to anti ghost stickers which
well not really the same thing did the
job give a lot of stickers oh yeah
that's it before they all have
sometimes it's not just a scene or a
lyric that needs to be changed up for a
different audience but a big part of the
design of a character entirely this
didn't happen much but one character in
particular proved a little bit
problematic to say the least we all know
jinx Berman blond-haired humanoid who
resembles a woman sort of well in jinxes
original design she looked a little
different instead of purple her skin was
black which immediately set off alarm
bells as she looked way too much like an
old racist stereotype that has long been
considered very offensive after some
serious backlash her skin color was
changed into the purple we know and love
today forever the episode transmitter
that we mentioned earlier well it turns
out it wasn't the only episode of
Pokemon that had to be taken off the air
surrounding the events of 9/11 another
one titled tend to cool and tend to
cruel that originally aired in manga age
was removed from broadcasting entirely
after the September 11th attacks it
wasn't directly insensitive towards the
tragedy but was just a little too close
to home to be comfortable in the episode
we see tend to cruel on a rampage in
destroying a bunch of skyscrapers in its
wake one of them happened to look just
like the World Trade Center so you can
see why the television network wouldn't
want this episode on the air no body
part seems to cause quite as many
problems with the sensors as a woman's
chest even if that chest in question
actually belongs to a cartoon dinosaur
we're talking about Nidoqueen whose
battle cry had to be changed for
American audiences in the game Pokemon
Stadium and yes we know she's not
actually a dinosaur but let's be real
here she could go to the Past the one
soon hi originally when a user selected
Nidoqueen for battle she would grab her
a repect oral area for emphasis and her
battle cry was changed for the american
version of the game Sally did before we
fail
you hear their names live Nora a gym
leader whose costume featured a pink
apron well that might not sound like a
big deal Lenora is one of the only black
characters in the Pokemon universe and
to make her a maid was just not it
wasn't the best originally in the game
the user was required to answer a bunch
of cooking quizzes before the battle as
well the American version Linares apron
was removed and the coding challenges
were replaced with trivia so it's not to
pigeonhole this character as a
stereotype sometimes it feels like the
creators of Pokemon often forget that
their main characters are actual
children specifically when it comes to
misty while she has mostly God would
carry something that on creepy had to be
adjusted before it could make it to
North America like one of her trading
cards trainer card called Misty's tears
misty is actually portrayed totally nude
this clearly did not fly in the West so
the image was changed to feature
squirtle wiping away the tears on
Misty's cheek while a strap from her
shirt can clearly be seen just to make
absolutely clear that she was in fact
closed while stove wiring has mostly
been the women who have taken the brunt
of the censorship there is actually one
case in which the male characters outfit
was seen as too racy for Western eyes as
well and pokemon gold and silver a
swimmer trainer characters along with
some female ones as well originally it
is designed the male trainer more HD
Neil and big style speedo for all the
international versions of the game it
was altered to a pair of more acceptable
trunks what's funny is that the female
trainers are still pictured in bikinis
whose bottoms are not unlike East champs
on the censored for the game's release
things like violence and underage nudity
we can understand censoring but when it
comes to food get a little bit more
confused
specifically rice one of the most common
and absolutely essential foods in
Japanese cuisine together with seaweed
known as onigiri in their lunches well
when the American Network began dubbing
Pokemon in English they barely had a
huge problem with right they even went
so far as to have Drock referred to as
onigiri has delicious jelly doughnuts
and later would actually edit out
WAIS and replaced with hamburgers one
came out in 1999 was a massive success
there's Mike not even realizes that
there was actually a pretty big
difference between the Japanese and
American versions of the film apparently
after the movie was released in Japan an
American distributor had some thoughts
about how American audiences would
relate better to an altered version of
the story but in the original version
Mewtwo was less of a straightforward bad
guy and was given a steam at the
beginning that detailed his backstory
and motivations but according to the
American notes Western audiences needed
a horn black-and-white villain for the
good guys to defeat so the scene was
removed and his story changed forever
every damn Pokemon was supposed to
conclude eventually and actually the
anime was supposed and after the release
of the very first movie but it was so
successful inmates much money
internationally the studio's felt they
had to keep going we know it was
supposed to end because in early
Japanese trailers for the film there's a
shot of an older Misti next to a young
girl she seems quite closely Wow very
comfortable in close to the child which
led most to believe that this was part
of a flash board into action Misty's
future as parents of course oh my god
and acid misty ever mean that changes
everything yeah of course we couldn't
finish without mentioning the most
infamous Pokemon episode that was bold
for broadcast oh yeah
we're talking about fibers older porygon
the episode with animations so flashy
and vibrant that it actually costs
thousands of children in Japan to
succumb to seizures Jesus one time in
Japan and was never seen again
the incident was heard around the world
I would even go on to be parody by the
citizens with a joke featuring a show
called battling ha ha
[Music]
no jinks should have been up a black
woman would have flung by well well
there's so much in there that was so
much fun that was that was 22 I thought
22 might be excessive to watch yeah
there's a lot in there before we hop
into what this video talked about did
you know that when John and I were young
and were made as best friends
was because we were so in a Pokemon and
that's what we would talk about
flash-forward to fourth grade this was
third grade around fourth grade time
there was a Pokemon album that came out
feature II of course the main title song
with the extended edition which had the
awesome guitar solo on it but there is a
song called misty song where she's
confessing her love for ash
John had a major crush on misty and we
all humiliated him at school
hence self-conscious white boy today
late 20s I'm very much responsible for a
lot of his emotional development anyway
this video is fascinating so many sexual
changes the 90s are so popular for
trying to put any windows in there it's
fascinating how it seems like in Asia
I don't know about Asia but Japan and
Europe they're a lot more comfortable
with sexuality and even though there was
some stuff about violent things we
talked about the gun episode we're
generally more comfortable with violence
like he brought the thing about guns in
pg-13
we're in other parts of the world that's
a lot more no no that's not that's not
okay but sexuality is okay and it's
funny how much we we shy away from them
because some of these are like pretty
raunchy like for American culture I
gotta say the shot of him like drinking
from the udder was just like thank you
it's very second or you know James with
the inflatable breasts why is that yeah
like there are some things that are very
direct but there's other things that are
just like a little ridiculous to me you
know that they were showing what was it
a game character who had a skirt and
then they had to slightly extend the
skirt to come and work I'm like it's
just a speedo yes women I don't know
although when I were a speedo at the
beach I am often yelled at and/or
arrested and so it kind of makes sense
to me other than what the cops are
saying and what the accusers are saying
I'm pretty sure it's because they think
I'm just too good looking at my body is
just too sexy to be on the beach in a
speedo that they have me arrested like
distracted yeah it's not because things
are actually falling out by accident in
front of families at the beach gotcha
mm-hmm there's a lot of 9/11 things a
lot of things that are in reference to
9/11 that I'm like one a couple of
simple changes could they could have
just like he said changed the title and
it probably wouldn't find it didn't look
like anything yeah wasn't like oh yeah
9/11 all those ghost attacks the other
one where he's like giant Dallas yeah
we're just shooting down the towers like
that yeah I can see that one being
pulled for the time it came out that
definitely makes sense because you know
nowadays we get so many destruction at
like the movies all the time
that it's not a big deal but I guess at
the time that does make sense but they
said it was primarily due to one
building looking like the World Trade
Center why didn't you just change the
one
building you know change the one
building that's it so yeah a lot of
sexual changes primarily sexual stuff
but there's a couple of like key note
things in terms of plot that totally
wowed me
I was like trying to find like a good I
was almost modeling okay I once told the
girl on the beach I was wearing a speedo
to cough on me and it's part of the guy
here I did the misty and ash ending that
the show is supposed to end that is so
shocking and the show he's supposed to
go to Viridian City compete in the big
tournament and then in the show he'd
lost and as a viewer even at a very
young age I was like screw this show I
stopped watching after it because I've
been watching for years room 2 gets of
yridian City and wind and my teenage
years expectation was like no I'm done
he lost yeah now they want to keep the
show going come on yeah
just dragging this out now I don't know
how this show ended with Ash's storyline
but having that flash-forward sequence I
was like cut out of the promos and Missy
and ash would have ended up together
maybe had children that's crazy they
should have done like a rerelease later
probably to make more money like just
like the original story and they were
saying how mu 2 had a whole backstory
that they cut out too because I wanted
to make him a black-and-white villain
unless nuance which is funny because I
watched detective Pikachu in the Mewtwo
character there seems very derivative of
the portrayal in Pokemon the first movie
which by the way sadly they said they're
gonna start up a Pokemon Cinematic
Universe what got me so weeks you could
be misty why get an Asian actress I'm
joke get a white girl nothing to do but
like the characters the character at was
black why can't you finish
I don't know and there was a white
female yeah Collini and then there was
white bad guys
there's one Japanese guy its diverse you
know and I mean the seizure episode
that's hilarious to me the way that the
Simpsons portrayed I mean if they
certainly did it's just something just
gone so terribly wrong I mean these kids
who are prone to seizures already you
know what I mean or is this the first
time having seizures it's not funny okay
we live in sensitive Twitter times I
know I just can't picture the cartoon
being able to cause seizures I like
wondering how intense was the flashes
how close relate to the television yeah
to me it sounds like 50% the shows fun
the bad parenting yeah shut up don't
watch TV so close that's insane
poor kids no one died right so we can
find it kind of funny if anyone died it
wouldn't be funny but because no one
died it's kind of funny but see Emma
seizures not funny sergeant like saying
that story as an adult you found out you
had seizures because you're watching
Pokemon yeah that's funny I thought it's
like grew up in Lego actually one time
logic Pokemon gave me a CD funny like
scarred for life I mean that's like the
Dark Twisted route you could take if the
kid wants to grow up and be a [ __ ]
everyone's second thrown up while
watching me and you can't watch it again
yeah yeah yeah all right I want to
clarify the concept is funny seizures
they're not know alright guys well did
you like this deep are you agree with
the changes us Americans made - Pokemon
because we gotta steer clear of racist
thoughts
thing was ridiculous a little bit a
little ridiculous a little bit but I
agree
can't have rice in my cartoons hell with
that subscribe to the real rejects click
the notification bell if you liked this
video sure that like button follow Sally
on her youtube channel and on social
media where weird thing I think I saw
recently she post bikini photos to get
you to watch her videos
that's smart yeah very very clever and
then the videos are all heard of bikinis
that's how you do it yeah X is U sub
vert expectations and hey I'm gonna give
a patron a shot to a man named JT our
Japanese man from Hawaii he messaged me
and said detective Pikachu is the best
video game movie I have ever seen I am
glad you are satisfied and the fact that
you were actually Japanese I hope that
you can go to a casting call one day and
not get hired and instead be told
they're looking for a white person to
play that role you're welcome
that's how you do it I hope you enjoyed
this Shadow JT
I saw your message on Twitter I will
make time to watch book-smart just for
you go support that movie